c'est comme si je m'étais réveillé d'un
seul coup on en met bon sens mais
pourquoi je ne suis pas chef
d'entreprise à la tête d'arte et cosy
sophie fait partie des lauréats 2020 du
réseau entreprendre yvelines il
accompagne les entrepreneurs dans la
création de leur entreprise soutenue
dans son projet elle lance en février
2021 son site de vente de meubles en
ligne des produits haut de gamme pour la
maison sa règle d'or considéra réconfort
les gens doivent être confortablement
assis pour les assises il faut que les
tables répondre à des cahiers des
charges on va dire de confort de vie
quotidienne de convivialité et donc
c'est réussir la gageure est la prouesse
d'allier des meubles qui sont
extrêmement novateur audacieux est
vraiment la qualité d'un confort
quotidien
la start up se place également sur la
décoration d'intérieur elle propose une
offre personnalisée en 3d aujourd'hui
sur arte causier vous pouvez envoyer la
photo de votre pièce nous on enlève les
modeler piennes et modem l'immeuble qui
sont dans cette pièce on vous la
modéliser en 3d et on vous fait une
préconisation décoratives avec les
meubles de notre site avec ses modèles
art et cosy soin de sortir de la
standardisation depuis sa création ils
sont six à avoir rejoint le projet j'ai
aussi ouvert quelque chose dans mon
passé donc du coup je le côté
entrepreneur m'a toujours intéressé donc
du coup de pouvoir apporter un peu ma
mon aide à l'édifice de sophie et donc
ce projet art et cosy samassa m'a tout
de suite beaucoup intéressés se sont
vraiment impliqués dans le projet même
si forcément sondés
des horaires et des heures 40 comptent
pas les heures comme là on est vraiment
dans le lancement du projet objectif
dans les années à venir enrichir
l'équipe et ouvrir une cinquantaine de
magasins en france